the lure of the neon lights and the
hustle and bustle is the stuff of legend
when it comes to Hollywood but it is
attracting a rather unsurprising breed
to the hills of Los Angeles Carter Evans
fills us in I've heard of many reports
of mountain lions through the years
living up here you just didn't have the
proof
exactly hi in the Hollywood Hills
conservationist Tony Tucci was curious
about the wildlife still thriving in
this urban jungle so I put the camera
right here he left it here in June and
captured the usual squirrels and deer
but earlier this week when he downloaded
the most recent images it was click boom
mountain lion my mind is blown several
mountain lions or Pumas are known to
inhabit the Santa Monica Mountains most
are tagged and well documented but the
big cat in this picture has no tracking
collar so nothing is known about its
whereabouts except that it likely had to
cross one of the busiest freeways in the
country to get here it's actually kind
of amazing actually that we still have
mountain lions in Los Angeles
seth riley an ecologist with the
National Park Service which tracks the
mountain lions says they're not usually
aggressive toward people it's pretty
clear that mountain lions don't think of
people as prey because this mountain
lion is seeing thousands of people every
day like if it thought of people as prey
it would have already attacked someone
what is a concern is how the big cat
will interact with the only other
mountain lion known to stalk this area
he's called p22 and he became something
of a celebrity when he was caught on
camera near the Hollywood sign and
mountain lions are extremely territorial
if it's a male what happens between p22
if it's a female
do they mate regardless of what happens
to cheese organization citizens for Los
Angeles wildlife or claw is trying to
protect the last few wildlife corridors
in LA including this undeveloped
plumbing why is this 17 acre parcel so
important why do you need to keep this
empty well because this is potentially
his living room or his den it needs to
be preserved and the hallways the
wildlife corridors also need to be
preserved so this animal can thrive
one knows how long the animal has been
living on this prime real estate but for
the time being at least this big city
cat remains one of Hollywood's more
elusive celebrities for CBS this morning
Saturday Carter Evans Hollywood even the
mountain lions are chased by paparazzi
and huh I love how Real Estate's
important even to mountain lion say it's
very expensive